Okay, if I'm still good, and by the way, Aaron, I know Aaron isn't going to be able to be
on to the very, very end.
So at about the three quarter mark, so I'd say, let's see, in about 45 minutes, Aaron's
going to do a screenshot and anyone that's on this, just as a reminder, anybody that's
on this, this live stream till the end, we're automatically going to send you the digital
resource that we're going to create from this thing.
So you guys don't have to worry so much about taking notes.
I want you to just sit there.
I want you to take notes of the things that come to your mind, not the things that I'm
saying.
Because the things that I'm saying, we're going to send you guys in a digital resource.
I want you to take notes on the things that come to your mind, the ideas that are generated
from the things that I'm saying.
I think those are the most important things.
Excuse me.
And then Aaron's going to send you a digital resource that we create.
So that said, guys, yeah, appreciate you guys being on.
We're going to keep doing these.
I like doing these sessions much better because the people that are on these are serious.
They're trying to actually make moves.
They're actually trying to do something with the information.
And it's not just a consumption fest like it sometimes turns into in the free group.
So I, again, I don't care if there's three people on this call.
It looks like we have about 14 people on this call, which is great.
Ironically, that's about the same or more than we were getting, even when we were going
live inside of Facebook.
So anyway, welcome to the call.
Appreciate you guys being on here.
And I'm going to make this worth your time.
This isn't something that I'm just going to pull out of my head, even though I could,
because I've done this.
I've talked about this a million times.
But I took, you know, I think it took me about 45 minutes.
I got all my thoughts on the paper, put them in order, exactly the things I want to cover
and I'm going to go over that right now.
So, guys, today we're going to be talking about niches and seasonality.
And if you haven't noticed already, I'm really harping on the, you know, the niche and city
selection first.
And the reason why there's a million things we could talk about, we could talk about sales
and there's a trillion things inside of sales.
We could talk about, you know, hooking business on which is part of sales, we could talk about
building lists, we could talk about what else could, I mean, there's
so many different things we could talk about, you know, doing the actual technical stuff
on your agency, setting up the business, what type of business.
There's really, really unlimited topics for me to talk about.
But again, as I've repeated the last couple of weeks is if you don't nail this part correctly,
everything becomes tough.
Everything becomes very difficult.
And so I've commonly said inside of, inside of digital landlords, inside of the free group
is the money is made in the buy, not the sell.
Meaning if you don't pick the niche and city correctly, it doesn't matter how good you
are at sales.
It doesn't matter how good you are at SEO.
Everything becomes more difficult.
Your ads are more expensive.
It's harder to rank.
It's harder to find the right business owner if you can even find one at all.
And on the flip side, if you've picked the right niche, you picked the right city, you
nail that.
Everything else becomes easy and easier.
I've had deals.
I specifically remember one, I didn't do so many due diligence worksheets, but I just
stumbled across a very, very, you know, I would say low hanging fruit is the term I
like to use something that, you know, there's high search volume.
It's a perfect niche.
It's also got a lot of, you know, it had, you know, very low competition.
I put up a website and it wasn't even something I was like, I didn't really have the bandwidth
to even build a website at that time, meaning I was so busy with other projects and pre-selling
and doing and trying to scale the specific niches.
But I just saw this, this opportunity and it was so good.
I was like, I'm a fool if I don't do this.
So I literally just went on, I bought the domain, I passed it over to my team, which
at the time consisted of like one person that I have hired in Africa, his name is Peter
and then Francesca.
And I said, Hey, can you just build this out?
Just get me like a thousand words on the homepage, 250 to 500 on the service pages, you know,
just the bare minimum.
Give me a tracking number and just like, I don't even want backlinks.
I don't want to worry about SEO, nothing.
I don't care about GMB, just get this thing live.
And I did this and I actually forgot about it.
I forgot about it for like six weeks and I was checking in with another client who I
had in mind when I built this because they had my site in the city next door within the
same niche.
And I went and reached, I just did like some basic stuff.
I cleared my search history and lo and behold, within six weeks, I was completely not just
on page one, but I was top two or three for every single search term.
And these are like the main key search terms in the city.
And I didn't do anything and I didn't even build the website completely how I like to
build it.
I usually like to do 2000 words on the homepage.
I like to do 500 to 1000 on the service pages.
H1 is done properly, H2 is done properly, the page titles, all that stuff.
We didn't really do it that great of a job, but because it was such a good opportunity,
I did nothing, just built the project, let it sit there, let it sizzle, let it simmer.
And I came back and in six weeks that thing was completely glued to the top.
So that is why I am such a big proponent and why I'm going to continually talk about the
city and niche combination, the due diligence.
And I know this is like the third week in a row that we've been talking about it with,
especially with this new format going into like really deep, nuanced stuff.
But this is important.
And like the topic today is we're going to talk about niches and seasonality.
And it may sound like something that you could cover in one sentence and I probably could.
However, at the same time, guys, I've lost thousands of dollars by not doing certain
things.
By the way, Aaron, there's somebody in the waiting room.
I don't know if you saw that.
And let me know if that'll let you admit them.
And also, Aaron, until we get to about the halfway mark, you can continue admitting people
after that.
Then don't make sure they're muted as well.
So today, guys, we're going to be talking about seasonality and niches.
For those of you that weren't on last week, for those of you that are maybe brand new
to the group, just a two second or maybe, I guess, 30 second brief on me is, you know,
obviously, my name is Nick.
I started the free group art of pre-selling or sorry, it was the art of pre-selling the
art of digital real estate.
I also started and run the group called Digital Landlords.
It's my paid community that I created from my experience in building and scaling a rank
and rent agency.
I've been doing this since 2016 with a tiny little, you know, shiny object, whatever in
there where I was gone for about nine months.
For the better part of eight years, I've been doing this.
I have lost millions, and I say millions, it's not just an arbitrary number, actually
multiple millions of dollars I have lost on building niches in the wrong cities, in the
wrong states, in the wrong building websites, sorry, in the wrong niches and cities, in
the wrong states.
I have lost money hiring the wrong people.
I've lost so much money on Google Ads.
And I've also made millions of dollars.
And over the last, since 2020, we have been doing at least seven figures and we're never
going to go back.
OK, so 2020, we finally figured out the missing pieces to this business model.
Many of you guys have probably heard of this business model, maybe in the past.
Build a website, rank it, go rent it out.
That's great.
There's missing pieces to it.
The due diligence process has to be perfect.
You have to consider the CPC.
You also need to realize if you want to scale this thing, you need to sell your website
first, get a client first, and then build a website on the back end, unless you have
unlimited time and unlimited money, you need to pre-sell and you need to flip this thing.
So I figured out all these missing pieces in 2020.
And in eight months, we went from eight to ten thousand dollars a month, with half of
that being SEO, to a hundred thousand dollars per month.
Eight months later, in July of 2020, a hundred percent lead generation, SEO was completely
separate.
I'd given that away and was taking a cut on it.
That was 2020.
In 2021, we did one point four or five million.
December 1st, 2021, after having so many different people hit me up with questions, hey, how
are you getting deals?
How are you selling?
How would blah, blah, blah.
I realized I needed to launch something and teach people how to do this the way that I
did.
The way that I did it that allowed me to scale.
So that said, that's kind of, I guess, would be what if you're sitting here going, why
the heck should I listen to this guy?
That's what I'm going to give you.
And at the same time, I want you to take everything that I'm giving you.
And I don't just want you to accept it.
I want you to think about it.
I want you to be intuitive about it.
And I want you to test it.
I don't want you to accept what I'm saying.
But I will tell you, I've been in this game a long time and I know what I'm talking about.
And if I don't, I don't say it.
So anything that I say is what I've done.
So that's a little bit of why I think it's worth your time to stay on this call, as well
as the fact for those of you that just joined at the end of this call, if you are still
on, we are going to send you a digital resource with notes.
Basically, it's going to look nice.
It's going to be a PDF.
You're going to be able to just, you know, quickly have all of the stuff that we cover
PDF.
And so that's kind of the deal.
So what the game plan is.
Hold on. Let's make sure we're muted here.
Yeah, so I just muted them.
No problem. Is there a setting you can just keep everyone auto muted when they join?
We'll check it out.
I'm trying to find it, but I'll just search it.
It's completely fine. And by the way, I do get it.
By the way, I've had this happen to me before.
So if that was you, it doesn't matter.
I just want to make sure that we can all get through this quick.
So here's kind of the outline of what I want to or I guess my promise to you on this
call is my goal for today's training over the next thirty nine.
Let's see, what is going to be forty five?
Yeah, forty four minutes is I want you guys to realize that things change
in this business as the seasons change.
OK, and there are certain things that you must do in order to protect yourself
against these changes.
And as well, I'm going to give you guys some tips for avoiding any issues
whatsoever that would normally arise as a result of the changing seasons.
Now, some of you guys are sitting here going, man, it's it's July, almost August.
We're still a couple of months away from, you know, winter, at least in the US.
And and by the way, if you're not in the US, then the same principles apply.
But your summer might be different than my summer.
Like I know in Australia, the summer I think is flipped.
Summer is during my winter in the US.
So just take the principles.
Don't necessarily, you know, go well on my summers at a different time.
Just take the principles that I'm teaching and then apply it to your situation.
I'm talking about it right now because this is something
that needs to be on your mind right now.
And it's going to affect the way you sell.
It's going to affect the niches that you go after, the cities that you go after,
the way that you do the deal, you structure the deal,
the things that you say to the business owner.
I know this sounds very nuanced and I don't want you guys to get overwhelmed.
But you need to understand that this is something I didn't know.
And two years in a row, it almost put me out of business
because I didn't understand this principle, OK,
which is that that niches have seasonality and it does matter.
OK, so the game plan for today's call is we're going to go as follows.
We're going to cover how the seasons affect this business.
What what you need to think about before selecting your niche,
which is going to be brief, because I've talked already about niches.
We're going to talk about what to consider when selecting a city slash state.
And then if you're not in a city slash state in the US, in your country,
whatever city is in the country you're targeting, which, by the way,
this does work in other countries, for those of you that are wondering about that question.
We're going to talk about how to preemptively solve any problems
with the business owner that would normally come as a result of seasonality.
And then we're going to talk about how to make sure your contracts match the seasons.
OK, and then if we have time, we're going to do some Q&A.
So that said, guys, let's one more time, if you stay to the end,
we're going to get you that digital resource because we appreciate you
giving your time and I want you taking notes on the things that come to your mind.
Not what I'm covering, because I'm going to give you the notes
on what we're covering in the form of that digital resource if you stay to the end.
OK, so let's talk first about
how the seasons actually affect this business.
This is a fact. OK, lead flow changes with the seasons.
No matter what anyone tells you, no matter how much you want to pretend it doesn't.
Leads are different in the spring than they are the week of Christmas.
That's just a fact, right?
Because of a million different reasons we're going to talk about today.
But just so you know, leads are going to change.
The flow of leads, the amount of leads that come in in specific niches
does change with the seasons. OK, just so everybody knows.
Another fact, OK, most home service
businesses slow down during the holidays and during the winter,
which is basically when it gets cold.
Let me repeat that most home service businesses
slow down during the holidays and when it gets cold.
Now, obviously, there's going to be stuff in there that might be,
you know, a little bit flipped, for example,
when it goes from getting being really hot and your AC goes on to,
you know, it starts to get cold and you kick on your heater.
It starts to stink and smell.
And then all of a sudden, oh, my gosh, I need to come and check my whatever my my
what the heck is it called my not my thermostat, my unit
that, you know, that little period of change is going to get going to give a spike.
But just what you guys need to understand, the majority of the niches
that we talk about that we target that I've made my money on the concretes,
the tree service, the fencing, the the the epoxy.
All of these things are negatively affected during Christmas
and the cold when it gets cold.
OK, again, if you're if it gets cold at a different time of the year than December,
then you need to consider the fact that that might affect you twice,
because no matter what, when it's holidays, people typically
aren't doing stuff on their house.
OK, that's just that's just really the case.
OK, when the seasons change and I'm talking about, you know,
when things start to get cold, when the holidays start to come up,
you know, probably from Halloween.
I know that's not really a holiday, but from October 31st until.
Honestly, until after the New Year,
definitely through January and then about mid February.
People's desire to fix their houses is pretty much like going down,
and it is the slowest from December 15th to December 31st.
That is a fact, and I can prove that I could show you so many examples.
People's desire to fix their homes, to do repairs,
to add concrete to whatever on their houses,
unless it's a complete emergency, like their tree is falling into their house.
It is going to be the slowest from December 15th to December 31st.
OK, and then for some weird reason at the first of the year,
even though it's still bloody cold, people like have some,
not all, but a lot of people, they have kind of like this like new,
hey, we're going to get things tightened up and we're going to do this.
That typically comes more during spring cleaning.
But you will see a little bit of an increase during the first of the year.
But I'm telling you, those last two weeks in December
are the slowest time of the year. OK.
I don't know other than the fact that when it's cold,
I don't think people are in the mood. They're not thinking about it.
But I also know that people are like they're out doing parties.
They're having parties at their house.
They're they're buying gifts for their kids.
They're traveling for for the holidays.
Money's not as expendable. Right.
And that's just a fact. OK.
Also note that like when the season starts to change from the cold
back to the warm, the spring, the spring cleaning itch, people,
there's a there's an uptick.
There's a really nice uptick in Leeds.
And hey, let's come in, you know, get our trees trimmed
and get that taken care of. Let's throw in that fence.
Let's get that artificial grass put in that we were talking about last fall.
We don't want to put it in during the winter.
Let's put it in.
We're not even able to use it during the winter.
Let's put it in now that the snow's starting to melt.
Or if it doesn't snow now that it's starting to get warm, we can go out by the pool.
Let's throw in that fire pit.
Let's do that outdoor kitchen or whatever the case is.
As the season starts to change to warmer weather
based on the niches that we target and talk about basic home service niches,
you are going to see an uptick. OK.
And one of the things I want to add just as something to remember
is there is a strong correlation.
And I know this because I've I've heard people say it is when tax returns
start to come back to people, you start to see an uptick as well.
OK, people get their check, especially like obviously W-2.
They go if you're on a W-2, you go and you submit your taxes
and then you get your return, whatever.
A lot of people take that money and they put it into fixing up their house.
You know, pressure washing the the the entire house.
Epoxying the garage, whatever the case is.
And these are things that I have not just heard is or not.
This isn't data points.
This is from experience.
I have seen it, guys, my first two years in business.
OK, like actual because I did it the first year.
I got sidetracked, whatever.
So 2017, I would say my first three.
Let me not even lie to you guys.
My first three years, 17, I basically only had SEO clients
because I was trying to like just make money to pay the bills.
OK, because I was coming off the back end of a failed business.
17, I was doing SEO because I just need to pay the bills.
18 and 19, I got wrecked during the holidays.
I got absolutely wrecked.
And what happened to me is in 2018,
the biggest time I got wrecked was in 19
because 18 something happened that kind of like confused me.
And I thought that, you know, I was safe.
But the mistake that I made, guys, is and this is another reason
I could sit here and talk about this all day long.
But another one of the 50 reasons
why you should be doing flat fee regeneration and not paper
lead or commission deals or, you know, profit splitting is for me.
What ended up happening is a lot of my deals were on paper
lead back in 2018, 2019.
I thought that was the holy grail of of how to structure this business.
OK, and what ended up happening is I had like some pretty solid months,
July, August, September, even October.
And in 2018, November, go figure,
was, I think, my biggest month of the year.
And what had happened is I was in a specific industry
that, you know, was affected by weather.
And the industry was basement waterproofing.
OK, and what happened is in October, I believe it was maybe September.
I happen to have sites in states that got hit by hurricanes.
Yeah, I think it's called hurricanes or typhoons.
I think it's hurricanes anyway. Yeah.
So what happened is September, October, these storms came in,
completely wiped out houses and flooded basements and all this stuff.
And so it took a while for the insurance people to come out
and, you know, quote them whatever to clean up.
And November was phenomenal for me.
I mean, we had so many leads.
And at the time, I was getting paid per lead.
So I thought I'd figured out the game.
Huge November.
I'm trying to make my projections based on like October was good.
September was good. October was better.
November is amazing.
And I'm like, dude, this is it's just going to get better.
And then December 2018, we literally just completely craft the bet.
I mean, our revenue went to like 25 percent
because all of our deals, for the most part, were on paper lead.
So if no leads come in, no revenue comes in.
Imagine, right, like all of my employees I've got.
I've got an office space.
I've got, you know, vacation I've budgeted for.
I got Christmas coming up.
I've got all these different things I want to do.
And I'm on a paper lead model.
And all the leads that were good during November.
Now people are pausing because it's the holidays.
OK, even though they need to fix it, they're going to wait until the spring.
And guys, I got absolutely wrecked that that December, like absolutely wrecked.
I remember I was like nervous, like this is not good.
I was worried about my business.
I was worried about having to let people go.
I was worried about the fact that I had a lease on a rent payment on an office.
I was worried about buying.
I mean, everything was terrible.
It was just so terrible because I couldn't really control it.
OK, and because I'm an idiot, the next year, 2019, I all of 2019,
I continue to do paper lead for the most part.
Hey, it's just I was like, yeah, it's just because the niche, right?
It's just because I was in basement, waterproof and I need to go.
So I did paper lead, but I did it in different niches.
Started expanding into foundation repair and a few different things.
Lo and behold, same exact thing happened to me in 2019.
And this time it happened to me starting from end of October, November and December.
So I had like a two and a half month just tank and it was bad.
And if you guys remember my story, which I shared a little bit of at the beginning,
2019, December was kind of my like, all right,
draw a line in the sand or get out of this business, figure out,
are you going to go all in on this or are you not going to go all in on this?
But here's here's your moment.
And so I want to go like the reason I'm harping on this today, guys,
is because I have literally had some really depressing
November, December's and enough that it
it really, really made me like question this business model.
And it wasn't because of the business model is because I was an idiot
and I was structuring it incorrectly.
So if you haven't heard any of my content or me talk about paper lead,
go to YouTube, type in paper lead, Nick Wood, paper
lead, digital real estate, whatever you're going to see my videos.
I am not a fan of paper lead for those reasons. OK.
So just so you guys know, there is seasonality to this business.
You are going to continue to get leads throughout the year to some degree.
Now, if you're in snow removal, probably going to get zero leads in July,
except for maybe somebody looking for a job.
But if you're in like just a regular service, tree service,
concrete, spray foam insulation, artificial grass, fencing, masonry,
you're going to get some leads during the slow time,
but it's going to be drastically different. OK.
So that is what I want to talk about in terms of like, just so you know,
you need to be aware, you can pretend it's not the case.
But the seasons do affect this business.
They do affect this business.
But I have a solution for you.
I'm going to get you there in just a second. OK.
You also want to talk about next is you guys need to consider this
when you're selecting your niche. OK.
So what I would recommend is just everything is going to be seasonal
to some degree, no matter what.
Everything is going to be some degree of seasonality.
You know, concrete is going to be slower in December.
That's just a fact.
Concrete is going to be slower in November than it is in in in, you know, April.
That's a fact.
You're not going to be able to completely avoid seasonality.
But what I would recommend is don't pick something that is the best
or is good just during the winter like snow removal,
like and by the way, I've done I didn't do snow removal
because I was smart enough that snow removal didn't make sense to me.
But I thought, you know what, it'd be interesting.
I should do a website for Christmas lights.
You know, Christmas light installation.
And I did it.
I can't remember if I even landed a deal
or if I was just sending over so I did get leads.
Of course, I built a site, got it right, got some leads.
Might even have the website.
In fact, let me check.
Be hilarious if I do. Let me just go like this.
I think I've got I told them to get rid of it because.
It just didn't make sense.
Let me see if I have this website still.
Let's see. Hang tight, is that me?
Oh, I do have it, huh?
I do have it, and I am ranked.
Number two, hilarious.
I don't even know if we got any leads last year.
I'm sure we did, but we don't even have a client for it.
Like, it's just a website that's ranked.
So I said not to get rid of it, I'm sure.
Christmas lights is good in end of November.
If you're in Utah, by the way,
people start hanging Christmas lights
the second the Thanksgiving's over.
In fact, Thanksgiving weekend, end of November and December.
That's it. After that, it's done.
OK, now I know there's some permanent Christmas light
businesses popping up, whatever.
I think it looks tacky.
Maybe it's just the company that's in my neighborhood.
I don't like it.
But I'm telling you guys, if you do Christmas lights,
if you do snow removal, it's going to be good for like two months, three months.
And then the rest of the year, there's no leads coming in.
So you can't expect that person.
It's going to be really tough to convince them, hey,
you're going to pay me this amount through the whole year,
but you're only going to get leads for two months.
That's really, really difficult.
So just my two cents.
I'm not interested in those niches.
I'm not interested in niches that are snow removal,
Christmas lights, stuff that only makes sense
during a very specific time of the year.
So the niche does matter.
Now, I'm not going to spend a ton of time because we've talked a lot about niches.
But just so you're aware, I'm not a fan of those niches
because there's not that much of a runway for you to get leads. OK.
OK, let's talk really quick about what to consider when selecting a city.
Just want to make, like I said before,
every city in the world is going to be affected to some degree
or another by seasonality.
You cannot avoid it.
But what I would just suggest really briefly on this topic
is try to avoid cities where it is extreme.
If there is extreme weather, I would avoid it because and it's not
that it's not going to work. It's not that you.
Oh, my gosh, I have a friend.
He's got some websites in that and he's doing.
That's great. It can work.
But it comes back to like, why make it harder on yourself if you don't have to?
If I can build for the same amount of money,
I can build a concrete website in Naples, Florida,
where the weather is moderate to good all year.
Concrete can be poured all year.
Or I could do it in Minneapolis, where it gets super cold.
Or, you know, Sioux Falls.
I think that's one of the Dakotas.
I think that just came out of my mouth.
Why on earth would I spend the same exact time
when I could get the say I could I could spend the same time
and have one that's going to be producing year round?
It just it doesn't make sense.
Now, if you live in Minneapolis,
then you might have an argument, hey, I have contacts here and that's whatever.
That's great. But if you're just living outside of these states,
do not try and target extreme freaking cities in the same way that I recommend.
I tell you guys, don't target California.
You can. But why?
Why are you making it harder on yourself?
Like, let's do the easiest thing we can do.
I'm lazy, guys. I'm going to be honest.
I want to do the most bare minimum thing I can do and make the most amount of money.
I'll put in the work.
But sometimes because we're willing to do the hard work,
we don't use our heads and we end up doing so much more work
than we need to do to get the same result. Right.
It's like I'm willing to go knock doors.
I did it for four years. I made good money.
I made a couple hundred grand a year.
I mean, from eighty thousand dollars my lowest year to two hundred and ten
thousand dollars in a four month, five month summer knocking doors.
Yes, I'm willing to do the hard work.
But then one day I was like, why the heck am I not using the Internet?
Why the heck am I using my time and trading my time for dollars?
Why don't I put the same energy and effort?
It's going to be my same 40 hour, 60 hour, 100 hour week.
Why don't I put it into something where I can use the Internet?
And now I can go and get deals without having to knock on a door.
And that's when I got into this. And guess what?
I'm putting in actually less work than I was,
way less mental and physical labor than I was when I was doing door knocking.
And I'm making millions of dollars a year versus a couple hundred
thousand dollars a year.
That was guaranteed because I was good at it and knew what to do.
But this I had leverage.
And so my point being, guys, I've done it.
I've tried the Dakotas. I've tried the Minnesotas.
I've tried these extreme.
I've tried the New York.
I have a website in Rochester.
I don't know if it's still a website, by the way.
The reason I don't know why some of these are alive
is because Francesca runs my agency, most most of my agency.
We meet. She updates me.
She gives I give her feedback.
Here's what we should do. Here's where we should focus.
Here's the guy that wants leads.
But she runs it.
I don't even know if we still have this website,
but we got this deal one time in Rochester, New York.
And I think we just targeted the area like idiots
because I wasn't thinking about seasonality.
And I think it was was it concrete, I believe.
And I went did my process, built a one pager, ran ads, got leads.
Boom, boom, boom. Sold somebody.
OK, a thousand bucks a month at minimum.
And I remember this because I very rarely do deals under a thousand.
Got the deal. And lo and behold, as soon as it got cold,
dudes calling me up, hey, we're we're not doing any more work until like January.
And I was like, what do you mean?
He's like, no, we actually like don't we don't we just don't even do it.
We just shut it down from now.
And he's like from about like he was like, whatever.
I think it was October.
It's like from mid November or end of November till February 15th.
He's like, we don't offer the service like we're not.
There's no work that happens.
And I didn't even know this.
I was like, you're joking.
No, we don't do it.
And so I there's nothing I could do.
I just had to like say, all right, well, I guess we'll talk in in March.
Right. And I've already built the website.
I've already got the deal.
I've already put the money into it.
So I'm trying to get you guys to just not make these mistakes that I made.
OK, there we go.
OK, now this is the good stuff.
This is the meat and potatoes.
What I want to talk about today.
There is always going to be seasonality.
You're going to deal with it.
It's part of the business.
It's part of every business.
I don't care what it is.
Retail is the opposite.
Right. Retail is the opposite.
They love Christmas.
Right. They love November, Black Friday,
because that's when everyone's buying Christmas.
Right. For us, we don't like Christmas because it's slow,
which I actually do love Christmas because it's when I take the time
to to put my foot on the gas and slash travel
because it does get a little bit slower.
But guys, this is the part I want to talk about, which is how to
how to preemptively solve any potential issues with the business owner.
Issues that normally would come as a result of seasonality.
You and I'm going to say this first.
I promise you they're going to come.
These issues are going to arise.
I don't care how cool your business owner is.
I don't care how long you know each other.
You guys went to high school.
If your buddy's paying you a thousand bucks a month
and you send him zero leads in November and December, it ain't going to fly.
I don't care how. Again, I don't care if it's your brother.
That might be different.
Maybe your brother is allergic to money,
but there is going to be an issue. OK.
So you know there's going to be an issue.
You know it's going to be a thing.
So what I always say in terms of this, I cover this in depth
inside of Digital Landlords.
Anyone that's on this call, I know Lane is.
He's inside Digital Landlords.
I talk very much about, you know, a lot of people say eliminate objections.
OK. I'm sorry. A lot of people say overcome objections.
And I like to say eliminate objections.
Overcoming an objection means that there's an objection that's presented.
And now you need to overcome it.
And what I found is that when you do that, you are on the defense
and you waited until they've presented an objection.
And now you have to overcome it. They voiced it.
It's a thing. They made it a thing. Now you have to overcome it.
On the flip side, if you know it's going to come and you bring it up first
and we call this preemptive, preemptively overcoming objections,
we bring it up first.
It is so much easier. OK.
And think about for those of you guys that have kids
or those of you guys have nieces or nephews or siblings, whatever.
It's like, for example, if you sit down and you're at dinner
and you tell the kids, you're like, look, if you finish this meal,
if you finish 10 bites, right, because with kids, it's bites
because they don't finish anything that's healthy.
If you will have five bites of your chicken,
then you're going to be able to have ice cream.
OK. And you just lay it out up front.
As the food's getting put, you get five bites.
You can have ice cream. OK.
Now, they still might throw a fit. It still might be a thing.
But compare that to when you just don't say anything.
You put the food down, they start making whatever their style.
And then somebody at the table is like, oh, do we have ice?
What's for dessert?
And the kid hears it. Ha ha.
Good luck trying to convince them to have five bites, right?
Because you didn't bring it up first.
And now it's a thing. Now it's an actual thing.
OK, that's one example.
Another example I'll give you is when I started my digital
landlords program back in 2021 December at that time, which, by the way,
thank goodness, this has kind of gone away at that time.
Google was really funny about suspending.
This does happen still.
And so I'll even say it on this call for those of you
that aren't in there yet.
Google was very fussy about suspending people on their accounts.
And you would have to verify your account.
They would spend your Google ad account for all kinds of different reasons.
Credit card didn't match.
You were too new to the gate.
No one even knew the answer.
OK, like everyone got suspended, including myself.
It's like they updated this thing and everybody started getting suspended
and everybody started freaking out.
I figured out how to get out of it.
And so I realized like there's a pretty damn good chance.
And this isn't necessarily as much the case now.
It's gotten a lot better.
But it was then when I first started, almost everybody was getting
suspended at some point.
And so what I ended up doing, I took the same principle
and I told Kyle when he started working with me and helping on board people,
I said, every single time you talk about Google ads,
I need you to let people know it's not an if, but it's a win.
When your ad account gets suspended, here's what you're going to do.
You're not going to freak out.
You're going to reach out to this person and we're going to.
Here's the steps. And it's going to take time.
Sometimes it takes 24 hours.
Sometimes it takes two weeks.
You can't control it. It's just going to happen because it did.
And that was like 80 percent of people were getting suspended, including me.
I got suspended and it was kind of a pain, whatever.
But I figured out how to get out of it.
As soon as we started doing that, guess what happened?
When people got the suspension, their posts, their messages went like,
oh, finally got suspended.
What's the next step? Or finally got suspended.
What can anyone offer?
Instead of, oh, my gosh, I got suspended, I got
and just freaking out.
If you bring it up first, it is not a thing.
If you don't bring it up first, it is a thing.
Last example I'll give you, because this is such an important thing.
If there's if there's an objection that keeps coming up, OK,
just start eliminating it.
I don't care if it's price, if it's contract,
if you keep seeing the same objection, start bringing it up.
I used to be terrified of flying.
I used to think that like I was going to die in an airplane crash.
Who knows? Maybe I will.
And honestly, I hope that I'm at least over a cool country,
like in like a jungle somewhere, not just over like stupid, like, I don't know.
Whatever was Lane said, frickin Joplin, Missouri.
Imagine I'd much rather die in like some jungle where a predator could eat me.
But I used to be terrified of flying.
I thought that was going to be the end of my life.
Whatever I thought about a lot.
And it would freak me out.
I swear to you, I had a couple of weird experiences
where like we had some really bad turbulence.
I'm like, dude, I'm going down.
Maybe you can relate. Maybe not. OK.
Some of you guys probably just have a few shots and you just sleep.
And that's the solution.
So anyway, this was the thing.
Like it would like consume my mind.
I would be like terrified, honestly, of upcoming flights.
And I remember getting on one flight has come back from Africa
and we were in New York
and there was a huge storm that like shut down the airport.
I was even more terrified.
Also, the like four days before that, there was a flight in Ethiopia
that like took off five minutes later, completely crashed.
Everyone on board died.
And by the way, it was the same exact plane as the one I was taking,
because I checked and I was like, oh, that's perfect. OK.
But this flight attendant or this pilot, I can't remember which one it was.
They got on the intercom.
They said, hey, look, we're in New York.
There's a storm.
You know, if we do a direct shot from New York to Vegas, there's a storm.
It's it's going to be rough.
So we're actually going to go down.
I think we went all the way down to like
Alabama or something to kind of go around the storm.
He's like, and just so you know, at about this point,
there is going to be turbulence.
It's going to be bumpy because we're getting some drifts from the storm.
That's completely normal.
But we should be good by about whatever, Kansas.
I don't remember if that's might be off.
Maybe it's New Mexico.
But he came on the intercom and he said this.
And I was like, OK.
And lo and behold, you know, I watched the map.
We went down and there was some pretty
like decent turbulence, like enough that it would have scared
the living daylights out of me.
But because he had brought it up first, I didn't think it was just like, OK,
he told me it's going to happen.
He didn't freak out.
Whatever. And so the point is, guys, if you guys will start bringing up,
this is the same for any kind of objection.
But if you will start bringing up these objections,
if you will start preemptively seeing the complaints
and the objections of people bringing them up and just
not waiting for them to get said to you, but you go to them,
it's going to be so much easier for you to overcome
or for you to still get the deal despite these things. OK.
So here's an example of what I like to do.
And I like to just bring it up.
And typically I bring it up on my sales call.
Now, this is part of my script that I have for those that are in digital
landlords. So those of you that are in, you'll see this as part of the script.
But this is one of the things that I'll say is, you know, near the end,
when I'm getting ready to close, I'll be like, you know, it's flat fee, whatever.
But just so you know, it's going to be completely transparent with you
because sometimes they'll ask a question, right?
Like, how many leads can we expect? Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And I'll say, look, Mr.
Business Hunter, let me be completely transparent with you.
There are going to be some months that are super slow, some some months
and some weeks that we're going to get no leads.
That's just the fact. Christmas.
Just go ahead and don't expect any leads.
Everyone is out drinking eggnog, whatever, spiked eggnog
and spending their money on whatever.
Like, just just go ahead and put it in your head.
You're not going to get any leads. That's just Christmas.
OK. And it's probably good timing because you're probably going to want to be
with your family anyway. But that is the truth.
It's going to be slow. OK.
No one's thinking no disrespect.
No one's thinking about putting up a fence during Christmas.
Todd, OK.
Not to say Todd's in here, but that's just a business on our example.
And then I'll say, but there's also going to be some months
that are going to be super busy like this.
You know, when people start getting their tax returns,
we're going to see a spike.
When it starts to get warm, you're going to start to see a spike.
But here's the deal. It's going to even out.
I'm not going to come and charge you extra money because we have a huge spike
in leads during tax returns or during the warm season or because of this
weather or that weather.
And on the flip side, you know, I'm not going to pause
payments or lower the price when it gets a little bit slow.
It all is going to even itself out.
So as long as we're on the same page,
I'm not going to do some kind of surge pricing like Uber does
just because we have a huge influx.
But you've got to be just just promise me you'll be patient with me
and not call and complain when things get a little bit slow,
because that's just going to be the case. OK, done.
That's all you've got to say.
Does that sound good, Mr.
Winsor? And if guys, if you say this two to three minute thing,
you are setting the expectation.
It takes literally 30 seconds to three minutes.
You could say that exact same thing.
I just said you saying that up front, being very clear,
very honest with them.
It is going to save you so many phone calls, so much heartache,
so many setbacks, so many.
I got to resell the deal to this person.
I got to find a new business owner.
It will save you so much in terms of resources, time, energy, money, etc.
If you don't, good luck, because you are going to get phone calls.
It takes you 30 seconds to three minutes.
If you do not, you are going to have a issue
because it's going to happen.
You're going to have things slow down.
So why not just bring it up first?
Now, for those of you that are on there like, oh, my gosh, I sold a business owner.
I didn't bring it up. What do I do?
Well, what you do is what I'm going to talk about
in my very last section of this training when we're talking about contracts.
But I just want to like emphasize to you guys that, you know, a lot of business,
a lot of like relationships is setting and managing expectations.
If a business owner is expecting that it's going to get slow in December.
It's not going to be a big deal.
If a business owner thinks it's going to be just great all year round.
It's going to be a thing. It's going to be a real thing.
You have to set the proper expectations and then manage those expectations.
And the other thing that happens, guys, I know when you when I say that,
you know, that line that I said, which is like, hey, just so you know,
it's going to be slow during Christmas.
I know in some of your minds, you might think that's going to hurt the deal.
But, you know, it's actually going to do the opposite because you being honest,
you, you know, painting this picture that's not 100 percent perfect
and making it seem real is going to create more trust with you.
And again, I've said this so many times, trust is the hardest objection to overcome.
And no deal is perfect.
No service is perfect. No business is perfect.
And so if you paint this picture of everything's going to be perfect
and the numbers are going to be great, you're going to make all this money.
It's going to sound too good to be true because it probably is.
So just know that when you say things like that and you don't just say,
yeah, it's going to be great and blah, blah, blah, and it should just be fine.
Just say it as it is, man.
It's probably going to be slow in the winter, dude.
That's just the truth. You know, that's just how it is.
So, you know, and if they start complaining, like, yeah, sure.
If you want me to, you know, if you want me to lower the price
during the winter, that's fine.
But when I I'm going to also charge you extra
when we start getting a surge in tax time and during the spring
and during, you know, the storms that increase.
So that's how I get around that.
OK, so just so you guys know, that's all you have to do is those two to three minutes.
Sometimes it can be 30 seconds.
And that will save you so much time.
OK, last thing I want to cover is how to make sure
that your contracts actually match the seasons.
OK, number one, I oh, by the way,
I know people that have that are in this game that don't do contracts.
And that's completely fine. That's their decision.
Contracts make me sleep at night.
Now, I have a whole thing.
I could go on because I'm going to say it, but contracts make me sleep.
And I have a contract on every single person I work with as much to set
expectations, just like I just said, as much to set expectations
as it is to actually legally bind them to the thing that we've agreed to.
OK, so number one, I always do contracts.
Number two, I always do a six month minimum contract if I can help.
But there are situations I'll do three months. OK.
But I also have a rule with contracts is I never let a contract expire
in the winter. OK, so or as things are starting to dip.
So I'm never going to let a contract expire in November, as it's probably
going to be slower than October, which means we're going downhill.
And then even if I sign them, it's going to be tough
because then in December, it's just tough, guys.
So I never let a contract expire during the slowdown
or during the winter months. OK. Period. End of story.
So what I'll do like right now, six months from now, it's it's July.
This is putting us in like it's a perfect example.
If we had a contract, right, that was six months.
We're I think we're going to end in December.
Like we're going to literally end December 29th, which is terrible.
You're going to be in the in the worst two weeks of the year. OK.
You're going to be trying to get them to sign a new contract
coming off the worst month of the year, the slowest month of the year
for most businesses. Good luck. It's going to be tough.
It's going to be very, very it's going to be tough to even keep them,
much less get them to sign a contract.
So what I typically do is like from right now until we get to about October.
So I'd say from now, August through the end of September,
maybe even mid October, I am going to be selling a either a nine month
contract or a three month contract.
OK, because I would rather my contract go August, September, October
ends in October and then I sign them for another six months or a year,
ideally a year, or I go August, September, October, November,
December, January, February, March, April.
OK, that's nine months.
I'd way rather my contract end in April after tax returns,
spring cleaning is starting to get warm, etc.
Then I would in November, December, January, February.
Do not sign a contract that's going to expire in those months.
November, December, January, February.
Don't have to listen to me. Go test it. Good luck.
Now, here's what I'll say to wrap this up.
Those of you that have signed contracts didn't even think about it.
You sign a six month contract, it's ending in December.
Oh, my gosh, what am I going to do?
Or you somehow signed one and then they wouldn't agree to an extension.
So you're on a month to month or you signed an extension that puts
and you just didn't even think about it. OK, here's what you do.
This is what I do is once winter starts to approach.
Usually for me, it's around like September.
I'll do an audit on all my clients. OK, how happy are they?
How many leads are we getting?
How many are they closing? How generally speaking, one to ten?
What's the health of the relationship? Is it is it a seven plus?
OK, we might be OK. Eight plus, we're definitely OK.
Anything less than a seven, then I'm going to take some action.
And what I'm going to do is I'm going to make October
end of September, maybe mid-September to mid-October.
I'm going to make it the most amazing 30 days they've ever worked with me. OK.
I am going to make sure that these guys remember who I am.
They know where the leads are coming from.
And I'll even go to the extent, guys, I'll go and I'll put on ads, you know,
150 bucks to 250 dollars in ads to supplement these deals.
Even if it puts me at a break even or a negative,
I will do that to get them to have this amazing last month with me.
And I will let them know like about two weeks out.
I'll be like, hey, I want to discuss with you about, you know, working together.
And I'll resign them into an agreement, even if my first one's not done yet.
We'll say, hey, let's just end that one, sign a new one.
I'll make sure they have the best 30 days of their life.
And then I'll go pitch the agreement. OK.
But if this is the reason I want to talk about this right now,
even though it's just barely the end of, you know, July 1st of August,
you guys have to start thinking about what kind of contracts you're selling
and then how to handle the contracts that you have sold
that are going to be putting you at a really bad time. OK.
Guys, there's nothing wrong, by the way, with running 150 bucks,
200 dollars, 250 bucks per month in ads for 30 days
to sign another six month agreement for six thousand dollars
at a 50 percent profit margin. That's three thousand dollars.
You're spending two hundred and fifty.
You're making three thousand net in your pocket.
That's a 10 X return.
It's not a bad use of money if I don't say.
And I'm not a math genius, but that sounds like one dollar for ten.
Sounds great. OK. You got to be strategic.
These are all the guys.
These are all the nuances. I never would have known this.
I was never taught this.
I was in all kinds of different programs.
No one talked to me about what to do in the winter,
what how to tee it up, how to get people, you know, juiced up
so I could resign.
And no one told me I for sure should do a contract. OK.
And you guys can run the business you want the way that you want to run it.
But again, the thing that I think you should consider
is what I said at the beginning is that I don't give advice.
I don't come on these calls unless I've done it.
And I have lost a lot of money.
I've had some very dark,
some cold, dark nights in the winter.
And I mean that in terms of physically because it's cold and it's dark.
Early is December.
And mentally, because I'm like, I don't know.
When you are in the winter months and you are on paper lead
or you just lost two clients and you only have four clients.
It feels like like heavy, man.
You're like, dude, is this business ever going to be good again?
And then sure enough, by like end of February, March,
things start to pick up, you start landing clients, people start calling you.
Hey, let's talk about that deal.
But it becomes very dark and it's very easy to give up.
It's very easy to get sidetracked.
It's very easy to start jumping to the next thing and having Chinese object syndrome.
So we're talking about this at the beginning of August and end of July
because it's coming up quick.
And I want you guys, as you sell your deals,
start selling deals right now to be thinking, hey,
let's either do a three month or nine.
I would prefer you guys do a nine month,
but three months better than a six month right now,
which I only would say because of the time of the year.
And these are just things that you guys have to think about. OK.
So imagine there is so much to this business that we've been able to talk about this.
One thing, the seasonality of niches, which I have a million other things
I could cover on this, but this is the overall the gist of this thing.
This is this is what you need to know about the seasonality of niches.
It does exist. It does affect everybody.
And you need to do things to not have it affect you slash.
If you have made mistakes, you need to do things to fight it
and correct it and nip it in the bud before it becomes a problem. OK.
Again, I'm just one person.
However, I have been able to use this model to literally build my dream life.
The the the exact thing that I wanted to do in 2016
when I signed up for my first program.
I remember they asked me like, what do you want?
Why do you want to join this?
What do you want to do?
And all I could think like above the money, above whatever.
There's two things.
Number one, the idea of being able to get out of my bed,
throw on a bathrobe and my slippers, walk into my office,
sit down and make money without having to go out in the heat
and make, you know, cold calls or cold knocks.
That sounded beyond amazing.
Like I couldn't even fathom that was a thing.
And this is before everyone is making money online.
I was like, how could what? That sounds amazing.
I can do it from home and then I can be done and just go to the fridge
and not have to have. It sounded amazing.
Number two was being able to travel the world
and make not just make enough, but make millions of dollars.
I wanted to see the world. I wanted to see.
I wanted to move to Africa.
I wanted to. That was a place that was very important to me.
I wanted to take my family there.
I wanted to see different places.
I wanted to go when it got cold.
I didn't want to be anywhere near the cold.
That was one of the things I didn't want to.
I don't want to see snow for me.
You guys, if you're skiers, that's cool.
And that's your thing. I don't ever want to see the cold.
And so it's it's been really, really fun.
And just being able to do this.
I'm in Dubai right now. If you guys didn't know this,
I'm in Dubai right now.
I've spent time in London. I spent time in Paris.
I spent time in Africa.
And it's only halfway through the year, I guess, eight months, seven months.
But I'm just telling you guys this because
I know some of you guys are sitting there stuck in a job,
stuck in a nine to five or stuck in a business that you can't move
because it's it's a business that is state.
It's it's you have to be there in order for the business to run.
And I'm just here to tell you guys that like it's man.
I personally just think life's too short to not see this entire planet.
If you're not going to travel, I think life's too short to have to be at work.
I was talking to somebody about this yesterday,
and I'm sure you guys have heard this, you know, a third of our life,
a third of our life, statistically, is spent at work.
A third. And I would assume another third spent sleeping.
So a third of it spent at work, a third of it spent sleeping.
And some of you guys hate what you do.
And some of you guys maybe don't hate what you do,
but you hate where you're doing it with.
Some of you guys maybe don't hate what you're doing it with or what you do,
but you hate, you know, the hours you have to do it.
And so I guess it's like, dude, you have a vehicle right in front of you
building simple assets, doing digital, building a digital real estate portfolio,
getting passive income and living whatever life you want to live.
If that means you want to be in Dubai, be in Dubai.
If that means you want to be in freaking whoever, wherever, Kansas and,
and, you know, hang out where you grew up.
That's it doesn't do that.
It's the best part. It doesn't matter.
By the way, I don't know if that's where you grew up, Lane.
I'm just that that no man's land, Kansas or Missouri thing.
It's hilarious. It's up to you.
You get to choose whatever life you want to live and go.
And this business will fit around it.
So I hope this was helpful for you guys.
There wasn't a ton of time for quite for questions, so I didn't even bother today.
But feel free to drop those inside of the Facebook group.
We also just one last reminder, guys, is
the digital resource we're going to create from this.
We will send it out to all of you guys that are on this call.
And yeah. And lastly, I've said this, if you guys haven't seen,
I made a new welcome post inside of the group.
But pay attention to what I'm doing, not just what I'm saying.
Why do you guys think? Think about this.
Why do you guys think I'm coming on and I'm doing these lives?
Why do you think I'm this? You guys didn't pay me.
I don't even know. Some of you guys don't even have your name on here.
Got Discord user. Right. I don't know who you are.
That's fine. But what I know is that if you guys are paying attention,
you guys can see I'm using my same exact process
that I teach inside of digital landlords.
I am using it right now with you guys and I am giving you guys free leads.
Free leads being you guys are interested in this model.
You guys are interested in getting potentially getting involved.
You guys are interested in potentially, you know,
creating passive income with this model and doing this.
And I'm like, hey, I don't you know, I'm here to earn your business.
Of course, I'm not, you know, just a philanthropist.
But let me you guys test this out.
See what see what you think about some of my life, some of my trainings.
Think about the stuff that I'm giving away for free.
Think about what it's like to work with me on a paid level. OK.
So I just want you to know that anything you see me do inside of my group,
I want you to not just listen to what I'm saying, but pay attention to what I'm
doing. Guys, appreciate you being on.
We'll send you that resource and we will see you guys inside of the free group.
Next week. I'm out.